البدايه من تداعيات حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا حيث اتهم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
الولايات المتحده بانها تمثل تهديدا
وجوديا لروسيا انطلاقا من اوكرانيا
تصريحاته لافروف جاءت بالتزامن مع انطلاق
اجتماع وزراء خارجيه منظمه الامن والتعاون
الاوروبي في بولندا بغياب روسيا مفوضه
السياسه الخارجيه بالاتحاد الاوروبي اكد
من جهته على الحاجه لصيغه نظام الامني
جديد في اوروبا للمتابعه ينضم الينا من
موسكو مدير مكتب الجزيره
ظهر جوا من المركز الاعلامي منظمه الامن
والتعاون في جورج بولندا مراسل الجزيره
اسد الله الصاوي وابدا معك اسد من المواقف
الاوروبيه خلال هذا الاجتماع في ظل هذا
الظروف تحديدا ما يتعلق اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
نعم عبد القادر موقف الاوروبيه ومعظم
مواقف الدول الاعضاء السبعه والخمسين
الاعضاء في هذه المنظمه تركزت على امرين
مهمين اولا يجب محاسبه روسيا على ما
اعتبروه جرائم حرب ترتكب في اوكرانيا من
امثال هذه الجرائم كما اورد اكثر من مسؤول
استخدام الشتاء من او تسليح الشتاء بحسب
اا يعني تعبيرهم بمعنى انهم يستخدمون او
يستهدفون البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه من
اجل تعريض الشعب الاوكراني في مدن عده
مختلفه الى برد الشتاء القارس في هذه
البلاد وايضا الى الظلام الدامس في هذه في
هذا الموسم موسم الشتاء الذي يقول فيه همم
ليل هذه البلاد الامر الاخر هو مساله همم
اجبار روسيا على دفع كل الفرق همم اعاده
اعمار اوكرانيا سواء من الاموال الروسيه
مدى واموال همم الاغنياء الروس المقربين
من الرئيس في الاديمير بوتين التي جمدت
منذ بدا الحرب في شهر فبراير الماضي همم
او ايضا من اجل او عفوا عبر يعني ايجاد
تشريع يجبر روسيا اللاحقه على المساهمه في
اعاده اعمار اوكرانيا اكثر من عنوان خرج
من هذه الاجتماعات ايضا مثل ما قاله
الرئيس الهولندي عندما همم تحدث عن انه
اذا انتهت هذه الحرب بتغيير همم الحدود
فانها ستقود الى همم صراع اكثر مما هو
جاري الان في اوكرانيا وقال ايضا انه يجب
عدم السماح بالقبول باي اتفاق همم يعني
يغير حدود اوكرانيا بالقوه الا اذا وافق
الاوكران عليه الاجماعات مستمره عبد
القادر غدا اليوم الثاني والاخير ولكن حتى
الان اذانات استمر لموقف اا روسيا التي
تمثل في هذه الاجتماعات عبر سفيرها في
بولندا تحدثت كذلك همم
وكيله وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه فيكتوريا
نوولندا للصحفيين قبل قليل وقالت انها همم
يعني همم ان 55 دوله من الاعضاء ال 57 في
هذه المنظمه وقفوا ضد الموقف الروسي تحدث
ايضا
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وقال انه هناك حاجه لنظام امنيا
جديد في الاتحاد الاوروبي وهناك ايضا حاجه
لمحاكمه همم او لمحكمه خاصه من اجل محاكمه
من اسمائهم مرتكب جرائم الحرب الروس في
اوكرانيا دعونا نستمع لهذا لهذه التصريحات
صوت اسرائيل
وتريد اجبار الشعب الاوكراني على العيش في
الظلام والبرد في الشتاء هذه جريمه حرب
سنتناول هذا الموضوع وكيفيه تنفيذ اهداف
المنظمه عبر جهود المشتركه متعدده الاطراف
لتمهيد الطريق لاقامه النظام امني جديد في
اوروبا
يتكلم عن خطر وجودي
نعم عبد القادر مساء الخير خطر وجودي
تعتبرهم موسكو ااا
قادم من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وانيتو عبر على الاراضي الاوكرانيه بشكل
او باخر هو اعتراف روسي بان اوكرانيا
واستخدمت
او جسر متقدم لاستهداف في روسيا
وقال اليوم في مؤتمر صحفي خصصه في معظمه
لاجتماع وزراء خارجيه همم الدول همم منظمه
الامم والتعاون في اوروبا التي منع الوزير
الظروف من المشاركه همم فيها بسبب عدم
منحها تاشيره قال ان هذه المنظمه تحولت
بشكل او باخر الى اداه همم ليد الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي فعليا همم ابتعدت عن
كل همم المبادئ التي وضعت لها سينما فيما
يتعلق بالامن الجماعي في القاره الاوروبيه
هذا الامن الذي يجب ان يكون برايه الوزير
ظروف امنا المتساويه ويجب ان يكون غير
مجتزه وهذا ما دعت اليه روسيا في عده
مناسبات في ذلك عبد القادر من خلال
تقديمها رؤيتها او مقترحاتها للغرب بشان
ضمانات الامنيه همم وما هذا ما ذكر بها
اليوم وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ما في ما
يتعلق بحديث الغرب عن محكمه بحق روسيا
بسبب جرائم مزعومه في اوكرانيا او حتى
معاقبتها بدفع تعويضات هذا الموضوع لا
تاخذه روسيا على محمل الجد تعتبره همم
امرا همم
غير شرعيه هذا ما هكذا اليوم وزير
الخارجيه روسيا واكد ايضا المتحدث باسم
الكربلائي وبنسبه لروسيا هي مستعده للعوده
للحديث مع الغرب في ما يتعلق بالامن
الاوروبي ولكن ليس كما كان في السابق هي
لديها قواعد وشروط جديده يجب ان يبنى
عليها اي حوار امني في القرار الاوروبيه
طبعا ايضا لافروف انتقد بشده ومنظمه همم
الامن والتعاون في اوروبا خاصه هذا
الاجتماع الذي تتراس تتراسوا هذا العام
بولندا همم
هل عليها بانتقاداتهم كبيره حتى اعتبر
انها ساهمت في حفر همم لهذه المنظمه وانا
هذه المنظمه اصبح بشكل او باخر هيكل همم
همم ارشيفي هيكل لا تاثير له في القاره
الاوروبيه لنستمع لما قاله الظروف في هذا
شان عبد القادر
في اوروبا كليا واصبحت منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا نفسها كينا الهامشيه
لم يكن رؤساء منظمه الامن والتعاون في
اوروبا الحاليون في السنوات الاخيره
حارسين على الاطلاق على كسر هذا الاتجاه
السلبي لقد ذهب جيراننا البولنديون على
حفر قبري هذه المنظمه الدوال هذا العام
ودمر بقايا ثقافه التوافق
صور صور جميله موسكو واسد الصاوي من
البولنديه شكرا جزيلا لكم